southern border encounters are reaching
record highs you've heard about that so
what's happening is more than half of
our nation's governors are responding
they're taking matters into their own
hands this week 26 governors launched
the border strike force to secure the
southern border and alabama is one of
those states and lieutenant governor
will ainsworth joins us now lieutenant
governor great to have you on the
program this morning before we get to
the solution why don't we talk about
this issue of the southern border it's
too easy to dismiss as this as an
arizona problem a texas problem here we
are in alabama it's clearly an issue
that's important to alabama how does
illegal immigration impact alabama yeah
thank you hey great to have you in
alabama first so good to have you
talladega you know you look at how this
impacts alabama i'll give you a local
story i live in gunnersville alabama
split my time between there and
montgomery you know a small town just
recently in the last month we had
several teenage and college kids die
from a fentanyl overdose with the drug
batch that was you know tied back to
mexico and so when you look at the
amount of drugs that are coming into
america and president biden's failed
policies he hasn't protected the border
and so at the end of the day states are
having to step up i mean we're having to
do the job of the federal government and
you know certainly want to commend
governor ivy governor abbott and this
strike force is just one of the tools
we've got but we can't just sit there
and let people smuggle people and also
the human trafficking side when you look
at that and the fact that that's now
become maybe a bigger business
than the drug side we got a huge problem
and we have to solve it well you really
do bring that home to your small town in
alabama it's not just an employment
issue it's not just really even an
immigration issue it's a crime issue a
drug issue that
sadly cost the lives of some teenagers
in in your hometown all right now let's
talk about solution this strike force
talk to me about what these 26 governors
can get accomplished yeah i think first
we're gonna put boots on the ground
we're sending people from alabama
national guard we're sending law
enforcement members we're gonna put
people there i think you know making
sure that um you know we actually are
going to be committed to getting a wall
built but i think when you look at
having people on the ground to deter
that now look and there was a hero just
in texas media's not talking about no
fox news is other media where he went in
and saved illegal immigrants trying to
cross the stream but what's bad is i
mean they're sending the worst people
across and it's drug cartels and we've
got to put a stop to it so alabama's
going to continue to step up to the
plate and support border states and
continue to send people there you hear
that that really tragic story that you
bring up about the texas national
guardsmen who it looks like might have
died in trying to save an illegal
immigrant who was trafficking drugs
reportedly
saved their life might have lost his own
any hesitation then to send alabama
national guardsmen to go do this job
what does it make you think and feel and
perhaps consider yeah i mean president
trump said it but you can't have a
country without borders we have to have
borders and if the federal government is
going to fail then it's up to states to
act and alabama and other conservative
states should be all states right but
we're going to step up to the plate make
sure we protect our border we're going
to send resources we're going to send
people we're going to send money and
we're going to make sure you know
governor abbott has our full support in
alabama to make sure we stop this huge
problem i'm sure no hesitation on behalf
of those alabama national guardsmen i
know on the behalf of those texas
national guards and despite the price to
pay somebody must pay the price to
secure this border we appreciate
alabama's contribution as part of this
as well yeah now it's the right thing to
do and again let's talk about talladega
right hundreds of thousands of people
great to have fox and friends here and
uh you know alabama's obviously known
for rockets known for national
championships economies booming but
great to have you at talladega today
well we're glad to be here it's fun i
heard you slip in the national
championship thing there as well but
he's an auburn guy he's a war eagle but
he recognizes as we all do the dominance
right now of alabama lieutenant governor
williamsburg thank you yeah great to be
home